all right alexis
alexis where'd you grow up where are you
from originally i'm originally from
massachusetts um
close to boston massachusetts
i moved out here about six years ago and
tell me about your family growing up
okay uh growing up well i'm the daughter
of a drug addicted
mom with mental illness
my dad we had a pretty good relationship
growing up you know he was in and out of
my life
um
my mom's mental illness she really had a
lot to do with my my childhood in her
drug addiction she started using drugs
um
almost right after i was born you know i
feel like a lot growing up that i was
kind of like default for her starting to
use drugs because she's kind of like
told me that before
and um
she was she was supposed to do six years
in prison but she did most of her term
inside of a psych hospital
and we would go visit her a lot when i
was a kid not in jail but when she was
in the hospital we go visit her a lot
and i just remember
seeing that her neck was all cut up and
her arms were all cut up they look like
meatloaf
because i guess she had tried cutting
her neck and stuff when she was like in
prison and
it just it was horrible and she it's
just always been like that ever since
um
my childhood did have some you know some
good memories and stuff but
when she got out of the when she got out
of the hospital she was you know back
and forth in and out of our lives
i got taken away by dcf to go to
into state care
two times one time was when i was
six i believe
and then the other time was when i was
eleven i believe yeah eleven
um
the first time i was ever in a psych
ward was when i was nine
i cut my wrists and i went to this
mental hospital and then
after that
i probably been to the same mental
hospital about five more times
um until i was old enough to go to an
adult one
um
i mean your childhood sounds very
tumultuous
how would you describe it
was there any abuse like that yeah oh
yes i was sexually abused as well um
with my parents i wasn't i can't say i
was sexually abused but i lived with my
grandmother uh like a lot of my
childhood you know my dad would drop us
there for like it was supposed to be a
weekend and we would end up there for
you know a few years you know because he
wouldn't come back
but um one time i did get sexually
abused at my grandmother's house by one
of her friends because my grandmother is
also she's also addicted to crack in
heroin
so she would have a lot of um at that
time she would have a lot of shady
people over
and um the next time i was sexually
abused was when i was in foster care
there was an older woman and her husband
her husband had abused me in the shower
as well as his you know his biological
younger daughter he would abuse as well
after that i was abused i was sexually
abused inside of this group home one of
the staff members had come into our room
we had a room with multiple kids and he
come into the room at night and he
sexually abused me and there was a
couple other kids that he would do too
you know depending on the you know
different days
pretty much
yeah that was it for that my dad got us
back each time he got taken away once
the first time we got taken away for
about two years
the second time we got taken away we
were gone for about a year my dad you
know he got us back both times
um
the drug started for you at what what
point i'm sorry drugs started for you at
what point
um
about 17.
yeah um i was
you know the reason it all started was
because um before this i had to use no
drugs whatsoever i was totally against
it because of my mom and what i've seen
with her you know and my grandmother
but um
what happened was i had my first
boyfriend at
16 we actually met him on my 16th
birthday i was a virgin and everything
and he was a little bit older he was
about 21 at that time
and
so i lost my virginity to him and i
ended up being with him for about six
and a half years after that
um
but in the beginning of our relationship
like i said i just lost my virginity to
him so i was very um i was very
unexperienced so
he
introduced me to some girl
and i thought that he knew her and i
didn't find out till later that he never
even met her you just knew her from
online
and he had me hook up and have a
threesome with her
and
i was having like pains and stuff and
weird symptoms and i had went to the
hospital like maybe seven or eight times
within the next month month and a half
and they kept saying nothing was wrong
and then finally one morning at like 4
a.m i couldn't walk i screamed for my
dad and my dad brought me to our family
hospital down in cambridge which was
like an hour away
and as soon as i walked in the doors
they already knew it was wrong i had an
abscess the size of a peach on my ovary
okay i had 104 fever and i even
flatlined before i went down the surgery
i flatlined for i think 16 seconds then
they brought me down to certain
emergency surgery and i had to get my
left ovary removed and my left fallopian
tube removed
um and they found out that it was all
due because i ended up getting chlamydia
from this female that we had the
interaction with and i didn't know
because the hospital was telling me
everything was fine they even red
flagged me at some point and i never
even used drugs
but they ended up putting me on some
heavy pain medication after that surgery
and you know then they
cut me off of them so i started to get
sick then i started buying pills off the
streets
um my boyfriend at the time knew where
to get them and stuff and then it wasn't
long after that when i was about 17 that
i found a my mom was supposed to be
clean at this point this is one of the
points that she was back with us
i found a value that she left in the
bathroom when heroin in it and that's
the first time we tried harder and we
sniffed it and we were just high and
puking all day at the library
and after that is just we started
shooting it it was just a couple days
after that we started shooting it i
would shoot him up and i would shoot
myself up
um
then
yeah he and his his family was really
well off his mom had a lot of money
because of the husband she was with so
he we would go over his mom sometimes
you know and but she didn't really want
anything to do with my boyfriend at the
time like as far as like letting him
live in her house or even come to her
house sometimes because of the choices
he was making
so um
we got he got us kicked out of my dad's
house because my dad ended up letting us
move in with him when i was i was 17 and
my dad ended up letting him move in with
us and my dad says to to this day he
says that's the one mistake that he
wished he never made was letting my
boyfriend move in with us that young
and you know he started to physically
abuse me a lot too he was an alcoholic
he got off alcohol for me
um then we were just using drugs and he
started to get really abusive um you
know you choked me out punched me like
one time we were at his friend's house
and i had he he ended up drinking that
night and he like beat me up and the
next morning i remember i had an egg
like this on the side of my face
and i had my grandmother when she came
to pick us up the next day i lied to her
and told her i fell down the stairs
when we were drinking um he's almost
killed me a couple times you know by
choking me out until i was passed out
um he would do it in my dad's house and
my dad didn't know what was going on as
far as that because i would lie a lot
and try to make him seem better than he
was you know
and um you know they had ideas and stuff
you know even my sister said she didn't
truly know until after you know until
just recently that that was going on
so um
yeah and then we ended up coming out
here because he sent
his mom had sent him to rehab out here
so like i said she had money so she you
know sent him all the way across the
country to rehab out here and like
couple months later at this time i was
doing you know crack and heroin
i was even
messing around with one of the guys that
lived in my building because at this
point we had our own place and um before
we got sent over there we had our own
place in lawrence i believe it was like
a rooming house you know like a big
building where you get like one there's
a bunch of rooms and you get your own
run but it's a shared bathroom
and and and share kitchen and stuff
and so like yeah when he like left or
whatever i was messing around with this
one guy who lived in the building for
crack like me and my sister were both
messing around with him for crack
and so i was really skinny my face was
all picked out i was doing really bad
so
we came up with this bright idea because
i've always wanted to come to california
like ever since i was a kid you asked me
where i'm gonna end up i always said
california
so it was a perfect opportunity i want
to go to california and he he'll get out
and we'll try to start over there
you know and things just they weren't
they weren't going to you know well at
all they were pretty much
took up took off from where they left
off last before he left
you know like it lasted probably about a
week before
he ended up um
going back home because i had my current
boyfriend right now
i had
my boyfriend at that time and just
finished hitting me
so he went to sleep and i started
walking around santa monica by myself in
the middle of the night that's when i
ran into my boyfriend currently
and he said oh let's go to hollywood you
know and i'll have you back before
morning because i've wanted to see
hollywood because i knew i was going to
go home that day you know so before i
went home i was like okay yeah i'll go
see hollywood real quick took me about a
day and a half before i actually made it
back
and
my boyfriend was gone at the time and
something told me like deep down in my
stomach to just
just stick with it just go find yourself
back to where you left him
you know the guy you met or whatever and
just stick it out so i didn't contact my
family for like a year after that they
all thought i was dead or something
happened
um you know i knew if i contacted my
family then i was going to end up giving
in and going back home but something
told me i needed to separate myself from
that relationship
i just needed to and i found out a
couple years later that he actually
overdosed and died yeah
so
you know i know i kind of like blame
myself in a way because like
when whenever he would like you know go
out and overdose i was always there to
bring him back no one else was there to
do it but i always was so i kind of
blamed myself that i wasn't there to you
know to save them you know
how old are you now i'm 27 27 do you
have children
um no i hadn't yeah no i have no
children
because of what happened with my ovary
um
that's what i was wondering yeah i they
said that
i have a small chance of being able to
have a kid but it's going to be like
it's like a it's a small chance
it's like a 30 chance
you know i have of having kids and that
happened when i was when i was 17. yeah
you're homeless now yes how long have
you been in l.a uh about six years
homeless the whole time
well a couple times i was you know i had
like places to stay and stuff like one
time i was staying with this guy at his
house or whatever but then he started
doing some weird stuff like i woke up
and he was butt naked next to me jerking
off with his hand on my head
and i freaked out and i started like
punching him and stuff and i moved out
the next day
i've had a lot of opportunities but like
you know most of the opportunities are
just
i foresee to be like some crazy like
perverted stuff
like i could see that probably happening
so i don't accept them you know
what is your drug today um i use
fentanyl right now
yeah i'm originally a heroin addict yeah
right i use fentanyl and i use speed a
lot of heroin addicts turn her to
fentanyl yeah i don't shoot up anymore i
just i just smoked my fentanyl i stopped
shooting up when i was still doing
heroin though like i went through a few
days of
being like barely well just to get you
know get off the needles
but now yes now i don't shoot up and i
just smell how do you make money now
um i usually hold a sign in traffic i
hold a sign that says i'm struggling
from domestic violence please help which
is not really a lie because the reason
i'm here is because of domestic violence
like the reason i'm still here today
so that's usually how i make money or
sometimes i'll i'll go and i'll boost
like i'll steal stuff from stores
yeah you have not resorted to sex work
um
before i came out here
yes i was in that type of work i started
with my boyfriend at that time was
locked up in jail that's when i started
with my sister my sister's younger than
me but she got me introduced into that
you know so i would then when he got out
um
you know he was a little upset at first
but then he kind of got used to it and
you know because of the money it was
good money so he started you know
finding me dates and stuff and pimping
me out himself
you know and i remember a couple times
like when like i was too dope sick or i
just didn't want to go to work he would
beat me up because you know i didn't
want to go and he would make me go to
work
you know i remember one time he um he
actually raped me when he was drunk
yeah such a rough lifestyle for a young
lady
did you have dreams of doing something
different with your life when you were
young i still have dreams yeah you're so
young yeah
i i guess i am young but i guess i
really don't feel like it
you know i also got diagnosed with hiv
about three years back
i have hepatitis c as well
you're on medications for all that no
i'm actually starting to show symptoms
as of right now from the hiv like i have
real bad infection going on in my feet
right now like i have a lot of swords on
my feet and this is well you know is
because my body can't fight it off right
now because of my my compromised immune
system
so i'm starting to have some heavy
symptoms due to it um
i am going to go and get on medication
like it's at that point where i'm going
to go get on within the next week for
sure
what emotions does this all this bring
up in you
trying to like hold back to yours a
little bit
it's gotta be depressing it's bringing
him out a lot because i try to like go
on in my life like not thinking about it
you know and i try to just worry about
my life right now and
just like don't think about it don't
speak of it
you know and kind of just like go on
like that so you know it's kind of
bringing up a lot of stuff that i
usually don't speak about
to anybody
you know some of the stuff i haven't
even told my parents about
my mom ended up dying too
she ended up dying while i was out here
a couple years back
i found out that she had um she ended up
getting something in her heart
called um what's it called um it's like
you have like a parasite in your heart
um
endocarditis
and i found out that she because my mom
she was very suicidal growing up you
know she was very suicidal like
she was in and out of psych hospitals
just like i was and
you know my sister as well was going
through same problems and she um she was
in and out of all four of her kids lives
you know and
she
she just really like she was sad she was
a sad woman you know she was in a lot of
pain you know a lot of pain when she was
living
and i found out that like she didn't
want to sign off on the surgery to get
rid of it
and they my grandfather wouldn't refuse
to sign off on it she i mean refused to
sign it so that the paper so they
wouldn't give it to her and then my dad
refused to and then she tried to tell
the doctors you know or change the name
on on the
on the uh what's that paper called that
you sign
that you um somebody can make the
decision
oh yeah
yeah
that paper and then she tried changing
it to my name because she knew that
nobody can touch me at that point or it
was hard to get in touch with me but
they they wouldn't let her do that and
so she just ended up killing herself
that night in the hospital i guess
and then i got you know i found out
afterwards after the fact about it i
found out after the funeral
oh wait no no i found out before the
funeral and i was supposed to i was
supposed to um
i wanted to go back for the funeral but
i just never made it back
what do you think it was about your life
that your childhood set you your life on
this path
if there's one thing
i think
the main thing would probably have to be
the
being around
just
being around you know like the type of
you know um
environment i was in a lot you know
because when i was like living with my
grandmother for a long time too you know
she she was drug abuse all up in and out
of the house
you know and just the things i've seen
you know like when after i got my
surgery i was
i remember i was laying on the the
lazy boy chair next my in this woman
this woman that was a friend of our
families was laying on the couch next to
the chair and i remember i was just in
and out you know knocking in and out and
in and out and then we realized that
because i realized she hadn't moved
positions in the past six hours we were
laying there and we found out that she
was actually dead there next to me on
the couch for six hours and i didn't
notice
six or seven hours
she ended up killing herself i guess she
took a bunch of um a bunch of drugs
ended up killing herself she left to
know and everything
she had a little daughter i remember
and alexis what uh what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life
i've actually learned a lot
um
[Music]
you might say the most important lesson
is
is to actually learn from your lessons
seriously to like
actually you know
pay attention to
you know
things that you you know that you're
discovering and actually
listen to that you know and actually use
it to make a change
you know because if you don't you're
just going to keep on going the same
same thing you know just ignoring you
know what life is actually trying to
throw at you
and trying to teach you you know
all right alexis thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you i wish you the best of luck
thank you thank you
you